[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi.
I'm Tamara Krinsky
for "Women of Marvel."
And I am here with the legendary
singer, songwriter, and rock
star, Nancy Wilson from Heart.
Hey, Nancy, how's it going?
Really good.
I'm better now.
Well, it's an honor to
be here with you today.
And we're going to
talk about firsts.
So your song is in this
film, "Crazy on You."
Yeah.
And how did it
feel when the song
became a part of this film?
It's an honor
to be in the film
because the film
itself, I thought,
was so aspirational,
for women in particular.
You know what
is really amazing,
I think, the way they
use music in this movie
to help tell the story.
And I mean, it's got the
first female composer
of a Marvel Studio's movie.
- I know.
You know, you certainly--
NANCY WILSON: Director.
--know something
about film composing.
So--
Yeah, it's just really great
to see teamwork like that
and women sort of being
encouraged now more
and allowed more, given the
opportunities like that.
So if you were going to give
a message to a lot of the girls
today about leadership and
what you need to do, what
would you want to say to them?
I think it's important
to lead with grace.
Because if you push people
because you think you can lead
them, or get them to
do something, or make
them do things, it's
never effective.
But you have to be
strong gracefully.
[LAUGHTER]
Yes.
- It's tough.
Right?
Well, people would always
tell me, like, what--
how can you be
out front wielding
that great big guitar on
a big, loud rock stage
and still maintain
your femininity?
And I was like, well,
being myself, I guess.
Well, and I think
that's actually
a theme of "Captain
Marvel," the things
that you're passionate about.
I mean, you're so passionate
about guitar playing.
And you've got a
character like Carol
Danvers who's so passionate
about everything she does--
NANCY WILSON: Exactly.
- --about flying.
With a guitar, I feel like
a superhero who could fly.
Yeah.
I really relate to the
character in the movie a lot.
Yeah.
Well, thank you so much
for talking with us, Nancy.
Thanks.
TAMARA KRINSKY: This
has been a blast.
You can get Marvel Studios
"Captain Marvel" on digital,
Blu-ray, or 4K Ultra HD.
[MUSIC PLAYING]